[Music]
a polarizing vote in New York's Lower
Manhattan splitting many Touched by the
911 attacks now officials have given the
green light to build a moss near Ground
Zero but does this help or hurt what is
still very much an ongoing healing
process Here's Lucy Yang from affiliate
WABC it was a rockus and impassioned
meeting in Manhattan as community board
one considered whether or not to support
a mosque near the former World Trade
Center there are 200 mosques in New York
and yet another one is not a big
deal calm down calming down easier said
than done as Speaker after speaker
railed against the Islamic Center this
is an insult this is demeaning this is
humiliating that you would build a
shrine to the very ideology that
inspired the attacks of 911
this house of evil will be the
birthplace of the next terrorist event
we feel 911 very very much we belong in
this area the old Burlington Coat
Factory at 45 Parkplace has already been
purchased and plans are underway to
build the Cordoba house a 15f floor
Islamic Museum cultural center and
prayer space right in the shadow of
ground zero in the end the board voted
overwhelmingly in support of the new
mosque which means the only way for
opponents to stop the plan now is to
have the building landmarked en la
Manhattan Lucy Yang Channel 7 Eyewitness
News well that debate is the topic of
our faces of Faith discussion this
morning Pamela Geller she is a director
the director with a group stop the
islamization of America and Ahmed
Solomon a Muslim and respected
journalists joining me on this uh from
New York and Philadelphia respectively
now pal I want to start off with you we
understand that there's a protest that
is planned today that you're leading uh
what is your group hope to accomplish
today and why are you against the
building of Cordova House this Muslim
and cultural Community
Center well Ground Zero is a war
memorial it's a burial ground and this
mosque is offensive it's humiliating
it's demeaning to the 3,000 innocent
victims that lost their lives without
Islam this attack would never have
happened and we are rallying at Ground
Zero at the corner of Liberty and Church
to show the public outcry and we're
asking that they be sensitive and
tolerant and responsive to this
overwhelming uh dissent to this Masque
the latest polls show that America is
against this mosque to build a shrine to
the ideology that inspired these
jihadist attack is insult
it is yeah I I want I want to read the
response here from the the Imam of the
of the of the mosque and the cultural
center because they've put this out here
and they want people like you and others
who are uh criticizing them to
understand what is going to take place
in this facility and they say that the
Cordoba house seeks to create a
community center where all people Muslim
Jews Christians and those of every faith
can gather in the spirit of Honor
respect and peaceful coexistence and
they go on to say that we cannot think
of a better expression to promote the
peaceful values of our faith than the
Cordoba house where American Muslims
stand together with fellow citizens to
condemn extremism and Terror it is a
project to honor those who were harmed
on September 11th uh why do you object
when they say you know that's not
correct what you're saying this Center
is not about uh promoting some sort of
hateful ideology it's quite the
opposite first of all that that
statement is deception because it is a
mosque and only Muslims can
pray only Muslims can pray in a mosque
the only time non-muslims are allowed in
a mosque is if if perhaps they would be
uh able to convert there is no plurality
there is no tolerance here not true
because the Imam says that they would
actually welcome people of various
faiths to go and check this out and you
can as a non-muslim I'm a non-muslim
I've been to a mosque before if you
invited to go as a guest as long as
you're respectful yes you you're invite
right you're invited to go for prosti
but it is not there is no plurality in
the mosque and my question is why there
how could it possibly be seen as
Outreach to build a mosque at the war
memorial that is Ground Zero how how
could that be perceived it is a kick in
the head I I don't understand how it can
be turned into this idea of Outreach
when it is the opposite it is a it is a
Triumph it's triumphal we know that in
Islamic pattern is to build giant
mosques on the cherished sites of
conquered lands we know this this is
Islamic history and it's cusing such I'd
like to ask you because there are
obviously Muslim Scholars and Muslims
who who disagree with you but also
President Bush made this point time and
time again when he reached out and and
said look we've got to go after the
those who attacked Americans on 911
Al-Qaeda uh certainly not uh marate
Muslims and not the faith of Islam that
there is a distinction that there's a
difference if people don't understand it
it's it's out of uh uh ignorance or
misunderstanding how do you counter that
point even President Bush said that what
you're saying is not
true I I counter that point by saying
read the Quran read the Hadith read the
Surah well they counter that well I mean
and and say that Islam there's nothing
in Islam it's a perversion of Islam to
it's a it's a Fai of
Peace yes I understand but you know the
Prime Minister of Turkey said there is
no extreme Islam there is no no moderate
Islam Islam is Islam there have been
15,000 Islamic attacks since 9/11 and it
is inspired by the threat Doctrine we
have to deal with it clearly a better
idea would to be build a center uh
dedicated to expunging the Quran of the
violent texts that Inspire Jihad every
jihadist attack has the emada uh of a
Muslim cleric I mean this is a fact we
can't rewrite reality we have to see we
have to deal with what's in front of us
or how are you going to how you going to
uh how you going to change things work
toward how do you counter the reality
that there are thousands of moss across
the United States and they are not
points or symbols of jihad or
hate we know from a research done by S
that that four out of five mosqu preach
a hate and preach incitement to violence
we know this as I said it's part of the
quranic text um and I think that it is
in I think it's deeply offensive to
build a mask on the sacred ground uh of
of 9/11 there is a piece of the plane in
that building and I think what we need
to do we we we're going to file a suit
with the federal government to designate
that building as a war memorial as a
Historic Landmark like Gettysburg like
Pearl Harbor there's a piece of that
plane in that building and to prey next
to that is repugnant to any decent
American any Muslim of conscience let me
tell you something I EMA from musl from
Muslims who who don't believe a mosque
should be there okay we're going to talk
to uh to another Muslim who has a point
of view as well real quick before you go
have you have you read the
Quran yes I have and so and I strongly
recommend Robert spences I strongly
recommend Robert Spence as the infidels
Guide to the Quran and iban warak and
Waffa sulan and and non Darwish these
are books from former Muslims that must
be read by the American people to
understand what it is they're facing
they just arrested two more Hadis they
were US citizens at JFK airport you have
to understand the threat Doctrine if
you're going to address the threat Miss
skell we're going to have to leave it
there uh we we're going to get another
point of view here Mr Solomon is joining
us here and I I want to ask you she says
she's read the Quran H I guess she's
pointing to a some passage in the Quran
where uh she believes that this is a a
faith that promotes uh violence and is
is there a portion is there a passage in
the Quran that uh promotes what we saw
Al-Qaeda do 911 well first let me thank
you for having me on and providing my
what I call typical Muslim perspective
um number one a few points I want to
make real quick unfortunately there's a
lot of erroneous translations that are
out there what we have to do is ask
ourselves what are they hoping to
accomplish with this protest today
against the mosque if they're asking the
government to stop it well that would be
holy unconstitutional it's one of the
first things I learned in law school
because it'd be a violation of equal
protection number one and number two of
The Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment something I learned in
kindergart Gard as well in America we
have freedom of religion Point number
two this is a fringe group a lot of
family members of the victims of 911 as
well as public officials and regular
Americans who understand American ideals
support this initiative because they
understand two crucial points French
groups like pamelas what they're doing
is number one spreading the erroneous
misinterpretation that the terrorists
like Al-Qaeda want to spread about Islam
and number two they're simultaneously
feeding the propaganda that Akai uses to
recruit which is that America is
anti-muslim now miss Geller and her
group may be anti-muslim but the rest of
America for the most part is not as far
as what iteller not understanding here
because she she clearly has a point of
view here that she feels threatened and
she feels that this is going to be
dangerous to have this mosque in that in
that area what do you want to say to her
well uh let's examine why she's
threatened number one she was talking
about what the Quran teaches there's 1.5
billion Muslims in the world now there's
admittedly probably tens of thousands of
al-Qaeda members or members of other
terrorist organizations they have
nothing to do with the teachings of
Islam she keeps equating Al-Qaeda and
their attack against this country with
what Islam teaches I'll take her to my
family in Egypt they'll F her they'll
fill her uh with food and they'll take
her shopping and they'll show her that
the vast majority of Muslims around the
world and not just in this country
follow the teachings of the Quran which
St for example in chapter 5:32 killing
one innocent person is like killing all
people and saving one innocent life is
like saving all people or another verse
that says let there be no compulsion in
religion another verse it says let there
be no tyranny this is what Islam really
teaches when you look at the accurate
majority translations that are out there
there are thousands of mosques already
in this country these are the teachings
of Jesus and Abraham and Muhammad that
they teach in Sunday schools it's what I
learned in Sunday school Growing Up So
this this MOS that they're going to be
building two blocks away from the world
Trade Center let's remember number one a
lot of Muslims died at the World Trade
Center number two this is going to be
Interfaith and open to to a lot of
non-muslims to use the pool use the
exhibit facilities to engage in the
dialogue just like a YMCA would and yes
Muslims are going to go pray there
because there's over a thousand Muslim
Americans who work downtown that need a
pray to pray sure let me let me ask you
this she makes the point she says that
this would be a very important symbol uh
to those who would want to do harm
because it's near Ground Zero do you
think that she has any kind of is is
that valid at all not at all the more
she talks the more it's clear that she
does not know what she's talking about
this mosque is a symbol of the 1.5
billion Muslims who respect peace I mean
remember that people go around in the
Muslim World saying peace be unto you as
hello and goodbye let alone the millions
of Muslim Americans including myself
including my brother-in-law who's an
officer in the Air Force Station in Iraq
right now teachers doctors these are
peaceloving American people their
relatives overseas are peaceloving
American Muslims this MOS provides a a
place to pray just like several other
mosques in New York City does for her to
say that it's offensive is what's
offensive to us because there's nothing
offensive about our religion mosques are
no different from synagogues and
churches and nowhere in this country
would someone go out there and and fight
against the creation of a church in
downtown Manhattan okay so Mr Mr I mean
it's really just offensive and and
there's a lot of ignorance out there and
the days when she can go out there and
make these untrue statements about the
religion are over we now have native
born english- speaking American citizen
citizens like myself with law degrees
who can finally go out there on shows
like yours that are nice enough to give
us an opportunity to respond and say
that she's on the wrong side of History
here we're going to have to leave it
there Mr Selman thank you so much uh for
joining us as well Pamela Geller as well
thank you and we'll be right back thank
you